hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
my Game of Thrones bonus video I wanted
to talk all about the dire wolves
so because the show is playing a little
fast and loose with what's going on in
the books I'm going to do a quick recap
of where all of them are right now dead
or alive and what I think is going to be
going on with them in season 5 I'm going
to spend a little bit more time on the
ones that are still alive for the most
part the show has caught up with the
direwolves book story speaking of which
I'm also giving away another copy of
world of Ice and Fire in this video all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment below at a
certain point I'm gonna have to
reference some things that George R
Martin recently said he just confirmed
some specific dire wolf stuff for winds
of winter or future books so I'll put up
an extra spoiler tag but just general
spoiler warning for everything through
season 4 on the show right now so
starting off where are all the dire
wolves right now gray wind was murdered
with Robb Stark during the red wedding
lady was killed by Ned Stark during
their journey to King's Landing
even though sophie turner totally
adopted her dire wolf in real life best
way for an animal actor to leave a show
hands down Viggo Mortensen actually did
the same thing with his horse from Lord
of the Rings after they finished filming
those movies Nymeria was turned loose by
Arya and is still alive presumed running
around the Riverlands a lot of this
videos gonna be devoted to her she was
the one that George R Martin was talking
about specifically summer is chilling
out with bran and the Bloodraven
underneath the giant weirwood north of
the wall shaggy-dog is hiding with Rick
and and OSHA and then ghost is still at
Castle black with Jon Snow where we are
in the show right now they haven't
changed a whole lot about the direwolves
from the books they've just omitted or
brushed over stuff so for the original
six are still alive and no I don't think
we're gonna see any of them reanimated
by White Walkers I always get a ton of
questions about dead characters people
want to see turn into White's Giants too
I always get a lot of questions about
giant White's I will say one of my
favorite things about the direwolves are
that they're bonded to the stark
children just like dragons bonded to
ancient Valerians or you could say how
Daenerys his dragons are bonded to her I
go so far as to say that the
relationship between the Starks and
their direwolves is even closer because
of their ability to warg the show in the
books have never addressed if Daenerys
has any dragon visions like she has
visions but she's not seeing through the
dragon's eyes in the way that the stark
children dream through the direwolves
eyes anytime they have dreams of running
around
it's like low-level passive warding and
I know George armed
hasn't said officially whether or not
all the stark children are able to work
but it is implied brains the only one so
far that has actually explored the
ability but he's extra special because
he's also a green seer so there are
extra factors in play there which is why
I think that the show is primarily
focused on him when it deals with wolf
dreams Rob is dead but if lady were
still alive I think that Sansa would
have wolf dreams - I call them wolf
dreams technically they're Ward dreams
the only reason I think we haven't seen
the dreams from John or richens
perspective just because it's
non-essential to the stories they've
been telling on the show anytime it cost
millions of dollars to show something on
screen they're always going to cut it
down to the bare essentials it's just
one of the many minor things that the
show has cut out from the books there
have been a lot of changes a lot of
changes going into season five I've
actually already done a video about that
so there's a link in the description if
you want to learn more about it that
being said because all those changes I
don't think we're going to see any
Nymeria shaggy-dog or summer in season
five Dan and Dave did confirm we would
open season five with a flashback but
brands group is essentially in a holding
pattern because they passed their story
in the books they're just waiting for
the rest of the show to catch up just to
explain some of that so at the end of
season four aria is basically where her
character is at the beginning of book
four brand at the end of season four is
where his character is at the end of
book five so all the characters are at
different points where they are in the
books its lens a little bit confusing
but it's really not that big a deal it's
just that there's no more story to tell
for bran and some of the other
characters until George R Martin
finishes wins a winter unless van a Dave
wanted to make up their own story which
I don't think that any of us want one of
the bad things about not doing dire wolf
stuff in season five is that I feel like
Nymeria is the most interesting dire
wolf yes ghost is awesome but I feel
like Nymeria is on a similar art to Arya
Stark not the same arc just you know
similar so I'm not going to be talking
about too much book stuff here but I'm
gonna put this spoiler tag up just
because George are Martin said some
things in an open public forum
technically not spoilers but get into
winds of winter dream of spring
predictions so as the last time she was
referenced in the books
Nymeria is still presumed running around
the Riverlands with a growing pack of
normal wolves
she's like the size of a pony at this
point so she's always going to be the
Alpha but by the end of book five it's
implied she has this giant super PAC
following her around normal wolf packs
in real life are like six or seven
wolves they can get as big as 15 if
there's like a really big
food source nearby so when george RR
martin says super PAC imagine double
that martin confirmed that the super PAC
would play an important role at some
point he didn't say how he just made it
like a funny Chekhov's gun type of
reference for anyone who's not a theater
geek that just means that in authors
never going to put a weapon in a story
without intending for it to be used so
Nymeria is pack in this case is that
weapon we don't know necessarily if arya
is ever going to see Nymeria again but
she still does have her war dreams no
matter where she goes in the world just
a boy crazy season 5 spoilers so jump up
north just a little bit from the river
lands back up to the north there's all
this tension building as Stannis marches
his army to Winterfell
to fight the Bolton's in the phrase who
are largely fighting months themselves
anyway even if arya doesn't come back
and start running around with Nymeria in
the super PAC I'd like to see them make
their way back up north and engage the
battle it just be sweet revenge for the
red wedding the matically I think that'd
just be an awesome way to tie things
back to book 3 there are a lot more
weddings that the phrase could have in
the books
so hopefully the Wolves will crash one
of those two it's just that I feel like
of all the battles teased in book 5 the
Battle of Winterfell
is the biggest I just feel like that
would be the biggest payoff and when you
think about it yeah the Riverlands are a
ways away from where Winterfell is but
wolves run really fast so in wolf terms
the distances in that grade add to that
the last time the super pack was
referenced winter was beginning to fall
in the Riverlands food was getting
really scarce in Nymeria x' pack has
started to eat people or at least
straight people meat is meat and a wolf
has to eat not to rhyme too much that
was kind of unintentional but you get
the idea
okay so spoilers over big question for
you guys to answer what do you think is
going to be happening with the dire
wolves either on the show or in the
books I know I did reference some winds
of winter predictions there's still no
official release date for the book
although I put it somewhere at the end
of 2016 at this point maybe 2017 fingers
crossed that we don't have to wait till
like Game of Thrones season 8
which reminds me congratulations to last
week's book winner William O'Neal you
get a copy of world of Ice and Fire
please message me on my channel for
details real quick update on the
telltale Game two some screen caps
recently leaked
I'm not going to repost them here it
basically looks like wolf among us The
Walking Dead game basically looks kind
of like that there were pictures of a
couple of the main characters I don't
know if the actors and the show did
their voices I expect the release day
for that to be somewhere between Black
Friday at the end of this month in the
second week of December usually new
games are released on Tuesdays so just
keep your eyes peeled when it gets here
my giveaway will just switch to copies
of the game I'll just give away couple
copies of the game it's going to be
totally awesome
so I will be doing gameplay videos on
this channel and my game channel which
I've actually been sorely neglecting I
will totally do more gameplay videos on
my game channel it's just that there's
so much TV happening right now I'm just
trying to get through it all feel free
to leave me requests for other bonus
videos but be sure to subscribe to get
everything I think my next bonus video
is going to be Targaryen related real
quick to the way I add links to videos
this changes a little YouTube gave me a
beta features so now if you're on your
mobile phone or a tablet you can see
links you can click on links look up at
the top of the frame here but the links
over here will still be the same so you
can click here to learn all about
ancient Valyria and click here to learn
about some of the big season 5 changes
that are happening thank you so much
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tomorrow
Oh